here I think you know the the political
discussion that you said about my party
um switching and all of that I think it
it it's a good place to just put down a
marker here
on what Maga is what the make America
great movement is and the other part of
my Vita I think that's interesting is
that I was one of only three
senior White House officials who served
with President Trump from the campaign
in 2016 all the way to the end only one
of three you think about that you're
going in the the you know the the odds
on me lasting the whole time given all
the politics that was in there but Mago
to me and this is why I I'm I'm a trump
Republican or a Reagan Democrat Trump
Republican it's it's it's it's it's it's
got such a bad rap Lately from the the
progressive wing of the Democrats but
but while Maggie is making America great
again
um is three things it's a triangle they
call it the Iron Triangle of populism
it's it's at the top of the the pyramid
there it's a strong American
manufacturing base and resilient Supply
chains which gives us the employment
opportunities the rising wages and by
the way the National Security we need
when we have pandemics or Wars and you
get that through things like you
mentioned tariffs but also buy American
hire American which I was the the point
guy in the White House
the second leg of the triangle is the
secure borders issue
um where as we speak uh we are having
the the biggest Invasion
um of illegal aliens across our Southern
border which brings um a whole host of
issues I'm all for immigration but but
we have to have a way to ensure that
that's going to benefit the people in
this country and right now that's not
the case and then the third part of that
triangle is an end to the endless Wars
the the afghanistans and the iraqs that
you know being in the Senate people to
the Hindu Kush to get blown up by IEDs I
got a lot of questions but that's Mega
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]